في مشهد غير مالوف اثار الرعب بين الماره
في بغداد بعدما قام رجل باطلاق نار عشوائي
في احد اكثر الشوارع اكتضاضا بالعاصمه
العراقيه حاملا كلاشنكوف
انتشر فيديو على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
خلال الساعات الماضيه لرجل مجهول يطلق
النار بشكل عشوائي على المره في حي
الجامعه بقلب بغداد بما تاهبت القوات
الامنيه المتواجده بالمنطقه لمحاصرته بعد
تبادل اطلاق النار استطاعت القاء القبض
عليه قبل ان يرتكب مجزره لا تحمد عقباها
ليتبين لاحقا ان المجهول كان يتعاطى
المخدرات ثم راح يطلق النار بشكل عشوائيا
من بندقيه كلاشنكوف وسط رعب وهلع حلى
بالمره نتابع
[موسيقى]
يشعر الى ان ظاهره التجاره المخدرات
وتعاطيها في العراق اصبحت افه بين فئه
الشباب خاصه ان هناك مساء يبذلها البرلمان
العراقي بالتعاون مع السلطات التنفيذيه
للحد من تلك الظاهره عبر تشكيل هيئه عليا
ترتبط بمجلس الوزراء واجراء تعديل على
قانون مكافحه المخدرات
[موسيقى]